afternoon already leading the race for
number 10 Rishi sunak even though he
hasn't yet officially said he's standing
the only one to publicly get the backing
of 100 MPS so far as it stands he's on
course to become the next prime minister
but there is one big obstacle on the
horizon Boris Johnson when the route
back to number 10 became clear he
returned from his family holiday
pictured on the plane alongside his wife
Carrie his Focus though on his Lifelong
Love Frontline politics
he's apparently been calling colleagues
trying to convince them he's changed but
still sporting the same Unique Style and
still dividing opinion among the party's
big names with former Home Secretary
Priti Patel tweeting her support saying
he has the Mandate and a proven track
record of getting the big decisions
right whilst former Ally Lord Frost said
he'll always be a hero for delivering
brexit but we must move on it was only
three months ago that he was forced out
of office now even some who served in
his cabinet so his past means he has no
immediate future in Number 10. the big
challenge for Boris is that we within
days over new prime minister being
announced next Friday the committee on
standards and privileges is going to
start taking testimony on partygate
that's going to involve Witnesses it
will I'm assuming have to involve him
giving oral evidence and we need a prime
minister that is Focus relentlessly and
consistently with a laser-like focus on
the issues facing the country and I
think it's very difficult to see how
Boris could be prime minister if he is
absorbed and distracted by all of that
but the Specter of more Scandal hasn't
stopped others backing his return here's
somebody I think who is a proven winner
but also a proven prime minister who has
helped this country through some really
difficult National and international
problems we once again face a cost of
living in crisis we Face other National
and international challenges I therefore
think it's time for us to bring back
Boris this should be the Rishi sunak
show because the former Chancellor is so
far ahead and yet all eyes are on Boris
Johnson and whether he can get enough
support from MPS to get to the next
stage that's when members would get
their say and would almost certainly put
him back into number 10. his team are
saying that privately he's got the
numbers publicly though he he's still
not there
the first out of the gate was
pennymordant she came third last time
around and is currently in the same
position with little hope of progressing
further
once on the same side now it's the
former Chancellor out in front opening
up a big gap in the latest race for
number 10. Boris Johnson is trying to
close it but time is running out
and Liz is in Westminster for us this
evening so Liz any update on whether
Boris Johnson has reached the magic 100
and even if he does will he stand
uh we don't have any answers on that at
the moment
um I think it's worth worth first of all
noting just the speed of this contest it
was Thursday that Liz trusted down as
the Prime Minister it's Saturday we've
got two clear Front Runners in Rishi
sunak and Boris Johnson although as you
say neither of them have actually
publicly officially thrown their hat
into the Ring of this contest Penny
Morden of course she has done that but
she is lagging very much behind them
it's so fast moving and it will continue
to be as it stands Rishi sunac is set to
be the next prime minister because he's
the only one that has met that threshold
of 100 MPS this could all change of
course if Boris Johnson hits that Target
as well I think two things to note today
first of all clearly the momentum is
behind the former Chancellor he's the
one getting the big endorsements from
people that you may not naturally assume
to be Richie sunx supporters Kenny
badinock the former deputy prime
minister Dominic Rabb Lord Frost as well
both of course served chances cabinet
both now supporting Rishi sunak at the
other thing worth noting today is that
Source close to Boris Johnson saying
that the former prime minister does have
the numbers to get over the line that's
raised quite a few eyebrows here in
Westminster because that would really
put him in a pretty unbeatable position
so why aren't those people willing to
say in public if they're backing him why
has he still not officially enter this
race no answers on that tonight the
other thing is there are still 160
conservative MPS who have not publicly
declared their positions so this could
all change so drastically within the
next 24 or 48 Hours the vote itself will
actually take place on Monday we could
have a new prime minister by then if
there are still two candidates it will
be Friday because it will go to the
membership but look within a week we
will know who is going to replace Liz
trust in number 10.